heidegger says
a crucial aspect of what it is to be us
is our throneness we're thrown into a
situation we're thrown into history
we're thrown into
our parental lineage we're and we don't
choose it that's stuff that we don't
choose we couldn't choose
if we were god and we existed outside of
time maybe
but we're not we're finite in the sense
that we have a beginning that we never
chose we have an end
that we're con you know often trying to
resist or put off or something
and in between there's a whole bunch of
stuff that organizes us without our ever
having
made the choice and without our being
the kind of being that could make the
choice to allow it to organize us
we have a complicated relationship to
that stuff
and i i think we should talk about that
at a certain point but the the first
move is to say search just got a
sort of descriptive problem he's missed
this basic fact that um there's an awful
there has to be an awful lot
about us
that's
settled
without our having made the choice to
settle it that way right the throneness
of life yeah you have that's a
fundamental part of life you can't just
escape it exactly you can't escape it
all together all together yeah exactly
you can't escape it all together but
nevertheless you are riding a wave
and you make a decision of the in the
writing of the way you can't control the
wave but you should be uh
like
as you ride it you should be making
certain kinds of decisions and take
responsibility
for it so
why does this
matter at all the the chain of decisions
you make
good well because they constitute you
they make you the person that you are so
you here's what's the opposite view
what's what's this view against
uh this view is against most of
philosophy from plato forward plato
plato says in the republic it's a kind
of myth but you know he he says people
understand
their their condition well if they if we
tell them this myth he says look when
you're born there's just a fact about
you your soul
is either gold silver or bronze that's
those are the three kinds of people
there are and you're born that way and
if your soul is gold then we should
identify that and make you a philosopher
king yeah and if your soul is silver
well you're not going to be a
philosopher king you're not capable of
it but you could be a good warrior
and we should make you that and if your
soul is bronze then you should be a
farmer a laborer or something like that
and that's a fact about you
that
identifies you forever and for always
independent of anything you do about it
and so that's the alternative view and
you you could have modern versions of it
you could say the thing that identifies
you is your iq or your genetic makeup or
the percentage of fast twitch muscle
fibers you've got or whatever it could
be something it's totally independent of
any choice that you've made independent
of the kind of thing about which you
could make a choice
and it
and it categorizes you it makes you the
person that you are that's the that's
the thing that started and the
existentialists are against
uh so
this idea that something about you is
forever limiting the space of possible
decisions you can make sarcha says no
the space is unlimited start is the the
philosopher of radical freedom radical
freedom yeah radical freedom and then
you could have other existentialists who
say look we we are free but we gotta we
gotta understand what the way in which
our freedom is limited by certain
aspects of the kind of being that we are
if we were radically free we really
would be like god in the traditional
medieval sense
and and not uh sort of these folks start
with the idea that look whatever we are
that's a kind of limit point that we're
not going to reach
so
what what are the ways in which we're
constrained that
that that being the way the medievals
understood him wasn't constrained
you